porque cree usted que alguien como pedro
castillo se hiciera hasta el momento con
el primer lugar qué posibilidades cree
que tiene en la segunda vuelta
ahora vamos por partes lo primero porque
tengo castillo diga que este
protagonismo cuanto a si no existieras
encuestas cuanto no juego en los últimos
15 días aparece pero en los últimos días
obra especial
en el tema de los números que se me
vería creciendo
pero castillo es un modo deportista en
la sociedad peruana hacia su clase
política por estos últimos cinco años en
los cuales analiza una serie de
problemas pero justamente investiga las
falencias
institucional en el país y por otro lado
también por la situación que atravesamos
actualmente con la crisis sanitaria y la
consecuencia
bastante garabitos entonces de alguna
otra manera ya ocurrió ha comparecido en
las elecciones convenciones
extraordinaria del año 2020 el año
pasado nosotros teníamos unas elecciones
especiales para el un postre
secretamente completar el mandato de un
congreso disuelto y segundo por otra
orientación de los israelíes tras el
mismo factor de lasarte el frepam de una
manera sorpresiva el electorado tuvo un
voto de protesta y esto parece que se ha
replicado ahora con la votación a favor
de tener un casting y como repito tengo
una propuesta extremadamente radical que
muchas veces se veía como que exagerar
al instante pero que finalmente no creen
muchos ciudadanos únicamente
ahora como decíamos previamente keiko
fujimori se está perfilando para la
segunda vuelta con un margen bastante
reñido que espacio importancia cuéntenos
ocupa el fujimorismo en la escena
política de perú
estima en cosa caso parece que sobran un
poco más porque yo hubo un continuo
rápido por parte de ir sostengo que ya
dio incluso habrán buena mañana como que
lo candidato para hacer una vuelta a ser
pero castillo y que comimos
se está corroborando con información de
progresivamente está indicando de la
obra pero que trata posibilidades
bastante altas porque porque si bien es
una pintura que tienen muchos
anticuerpos el fujimorismo básicamente
oficina 62 por ciento de rechazo por
parte de la población ocurre a años que
es extremadamente fuerte y es la
preocupación por uno de la noticia
radical la votación de un activo es una
mutación hepática presionamos votación
que responde a aceptar radicales y la
gran mayoría 90 metros entonces siempre
el ciclo sería una suerte de voto
voto a favor de que un rechazo sea un
poco forzado por esta plenitud